and Gabriel Elizondo joins us live now
from Washington DC Gabe so we understand
that House Speaker Nancy Pelosi has now
written a letter to House Democrats
about the issue of congressional
oversight for military operations what
does it say yeah Nancy Pelosi was
furious quite frankly that Trump
launched this air strikes that killed
soleimani without informing Congress in
advance on late Sunday evening she did
send a letter as about a page and a half
long to House Democrats and it was she
announced in the letter that the house
will vote next week on a War Powers
Resolution that could limit Trump's
ability to pursue any military action
against Iran in this letter she said
that the strike that killed sulemani was
provocative and disproportionate
military air strike she said that it
endangers our servicemembers diplomats
and others and risking serious
escalation in tensions with Iran in the
letter she said as members of Congress
our first responsibilities to keep the
American people safe for this reason we
are concerned that the administration
took this action without the
consultation of Congress and without the
respect for Congress's war powers
granted to it in the Constitution so you
can expect some action on Capitol Hill
and in the House of Representatives this
week as the Democrats and the powerful
Speaker of the House try to hold Trump
to account for his actions there the
Democrats in the house are also wanting
to get more information on the
justification that the administration
says that they have the intelligence
that the administration says that they
have on why they thought that this
strike at killing Soleimani was so
necessary and the so-called imminent
threat that Soleimani posed so expect to
see some political wrangling on Capitol
Hill this week and here in Washington
yeah David meanwhile President Trump has
been threatening to sanction Iraq and
also insists he may hit Iran's cultural
sites what was he been saying there yeah
Trump did not speak to reporters on
camera when he left Marlo go Resort in
Florida coming back to Washington but he
did speak to reporters off
on Air Force one and he said that the US
has spent trillions of dollars building
bases in Iraq and that if Iraq kicked
the u.s. out of that country that he
would won't expect that Iraq would repay
the United States and he said if they
didn't the US would level sanctions
against Iraq that he said would pale in
comparison to the current sanctions
against Iran so he's not only ramping up
the rhetoric and escalating the
situation with Iran but now also with
Iraq as well also on the cultural sites
the president told reporters that he
would consider striking Iranian cultural
sites this is a little bit of what the
president is quoted as saying he said
they're allowed to kill our people
they're allowed to torture and maim our
people they're allowed to use roadside
bombs and blow up our people and were
not allowed to touch their cultural site
it doesn't work that way those are the
words from President Trump raising a
really the eyebrows of a lot of people
because striking a cultural site is a
war crime according to the 1954 Hague
Convention that the u.s. signed on to
should be noted that the UN has
identified 24 locations in Iran that are
unesco world heritage sites so Trump
really threatening not only Iraq with
these sanctions but also threatening
Iran as well on multiple levels should
Iran decide to retaliate against the
United States all right a Gabriel
Elizondo there in Washington DC Gabe
thank you